die entscheidung des russischen
präsidenten zur anerkennung der
sogenannten volksrepublik hans und
nascar montag ist ein schwerwiegender
bruch des völkerrechts
präsident putin bricht damit nicht nur
das abkommen von minsk dass er 2014 15
selbst unterzeichnet hatte er bricht
auch mit den grundprinzipien wie sind
der charta der vereinten nationen zum
friedlichen zusammenleben der völker
verankert sind dazu gehören die wahrung
der territorialen integrität und
souveränität der staaten der verzicht
auf androhung und anwendung von gewalt
und die verpflichtung zur friedlichen
streitbeilegung
russland bricht auch mit allen
völkerrechtlichen vereinbarungen die
russland in den vergangenen fast 50
jahren ausdrücklich eingegangen ist
insbesondere der helsinki grundakten die
unversehrtheit und unverrückbar kite von
grenzen sowie die souveränität eines
jeden landes gilt es zu achten das ist
die basis auf diesem prinzip fußen weite
teile unserer nachkriegsordnung
mit der anerkennung der beiden provinzen
im osten der ukraine hat russland gegen
diese grundprinzipien verstoßen die lage
heute ist damit eine grundlegend andere
nun ist es an der internationalen
gemeinschaft auf diese einseitigen
unverständlichen und
ungerechtfertigten handlungen des
russischen präsidenten zu reagieren eng
abgestimmt gut koordiniert und
zielgerichtet
damit wir ein klares signal an moskau
senden dass solche handlungen nicht ohne
konsequenz bleiben werden
international stimmen wir uns eng ab im
un-sicherheitsrat haben wir und andere
staaten gestern nacht bereits deutlich
gemacht dass russland keinerlei rückhalt
hat in der welt für sein vorgehen
der ukrainische präsident zealand ski
verdient unseren höchsten respekt dafür
dass sich sein land nicht provozieren
lässt von russland denn genau darauf
wartet der russische präsident um ein
vorwand zu haben
möglicherweise die gesamte ukraine die
zu besetzen
innerhalb der europäischen union haben
wir ein erstes z an sanktionen
miteinander besprochen und werden sie
noch im laufe des tages gemeinsam
beschließen
sprach davon die lage ist heute eine
grundlegend andere
und deshalb
müssen wir angesichts der jüngsten
entwicklung diese lage auch neu bewerten
übrigens auch im hinblick auf aus dem 2
ich habe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heute
gebeten den bestehenden bericht zur
analyse der versorgungssicherheit bei
der bundesnetzagentur zurückzuziehen das
klingt zwar technisch ist aber der
nötige verwaltungsrechtliche schützt
damit jetzt keine zertifizierung der
pipeline erfolgen kann und ohne diese
zertifizierung kann aus dem zwei ja
nicht in betrieb gehen die zuständige
abteilung des
bundeswirtschaftsministerium wird eine
neue bewertung der sicherheit unserer
versorgung und der berücksichtigung
dessen vornehmen was sich in den
vergangenen tagen verändert hat in
dieser phase ist es jetzt wichtig neben
ersten sanktionen eine weitere
eskalation und damit eine katastrophe zu
verhindern
darauf zielen alle unsere diplomatischen
anstrengungen es sind sehr schwere tage
und stunden für europa knapp 80 jahre
nach dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges
droht ein krieg im osten europas es ist
unsere aufgabe eine solche katastrophe
abzuwenden und ich appelliere erneut an
russland dabei zu helfen vielen dank
in berlin
die wirtschaftlichen und
handelsbeziehungen mit unserer band
weiter so vertiefen wir arbeiten auch in
der europäischen union enger zusammen
denn wir haben in vielerlei hinsicht die
gleiche meinung in bezug auf
herausforderungen der kanzler und ich
möchten diese zusammenarbeit
weiterführen und vertiefen in unserem
nationalen interesse aber auch im
europäischen interesse ich freue mich
darauf die entwicklungen in der ukraine
mit dem kanzler
[Musik]
also meine damen und herren wir haben es
gerade hört gehört bundeskanzler scholz
hat es gesagt der behördliche vorgang
also die zertifizierung für nord stream
2 ist gestoppt worden bei der
bundesnetzagentur
das heißt nord stream 2 ist bis auf
weiteres gestoppt genau das was immer
wieder gefordert wurde was der
amerikanische präsident gefordert hat
der druck der da aufgebaut wurde auch
manfred weber hat es vorhin noch einmal
gesagt das ist also eine ja eine sehr
sehr starke botschaft an präsident putin
in nord stream zwei die russische gas
leitungen die fast fertig ist nur noch
zertifiziert werden muss ist gestoppt
die durch die ostsee führt und direkt
russisches gas nach deutschland bringt
eine immer schon umstrittene pipeline
und nord stream zwei auch ein projekt
muss man dazu sagen sandra von gerhard
schröder der dort im aufsichtsrat sitzt
der ehemalige spd vorsitzende das ist
also eine in der tat drastische maßnahme
mit der man vielleicht nicht unbedingt
sofort heute gerechnet sagte aber auch
dass es noch weitere sanktionen geben
werde die eu ist ein enger absprache und
wird heute nachmittag entscheiden und
sich dann auch schnellstmöglich melden
wie diese sanktionen dann auch
auszusehen haben